e aí a gente foi lá tudo com você olha
só que beleza e rubinho que nossa que
bom então
pois é meus amigos há um tempo que eu
nunca não assiste televisão fala galera
eu sempre lembro que eu tô nessa casa
que só tem trazido essa casa aqui porque
eu eu jogue o que acontece hoje eu fui
ligar a televisão e aqui vai
infelicidade de bater bem na mesma hora
do horário eleitoral gratuito não sei
nem o que dizer que é gratuita nessa
merda é gratuita pornô que os políticos
estão tão ladrão tomou abraão que eu
liguei a televisão no horário político
sumiu der meu bolso ela tá [ __ ] brasil
na guitarra liguei começou nervosa por
não machuca saber eu vou eu vou assistir
seu horário habitual tom e que a atitude
garoto tal e atitude garotão vamos
assistir horário gostará gratuito e
gente agora eleitoral pretende não sei
porque é que a pessoa quer fazer no meio
político e de uma campanha tão ódio de
ligar a televisão para ver o horário
eleitoral e ver e perceber que a pessoa
talento parece que nem sabe o que ela
faz vai fazer o cara tá só lendo o cara
tá lendo aliás proposta dele e parece
que nem ele não sabe o que quer fazer
oi e chama o hotmail nesse ano estou
aqui para falar que estamos pensando em
fazer novas estrada e novos lançamentos
estamos também pensando em a
infraestrutura e segura a segurança para
que possamos andar tranquilamente pelas
ruas com mais 1 phone
a minha proposta o love colocar e
educação em todos as crianças dada a da
rua aims robô da educação básica
a rua está na rua chique ter um outro
tem hoje tem um olho a mim que essa
pessoa ofende até o chão ela pisa em tão
boa é outra conteúdo em hora eleitoral é
daquelas pessoas que têm essa proposta
nada a ver as propostas do tipo olá meu
nome é joão pedro da da mata eu fui
eleito eu prometo criar uma lei
que vai proibir as pessoas mudarem a
sendo a if delas todas as senhas dos vai
faz será 12345 som eu prometo que se eu
for eleito todas as pessoas que tiverem
iphone 6
a gente vai decretar uma lei para pegar
o iphone 6 e virar de cabeça para baixo
ele virar um iphone 9 o time pra você
ganhar o seu espanhol o dia o meu nome
da ódio orde ou você sabe o que é ode to
falando hoje outra coisa que me deixa
puto muito puto quando eu assisto
eleitoral é gente tentando usar a
palavra de deus a poder convencer a
pessoa votar nele meu amigo minha amiga
licença para entrar na sua casa eu venho
aqui onde jesus enviado por deus pelos
acabei de falar com o facetime na
conexão a sap da unac enviar por ele
mesmo próprio emanuel o próprio jesus
nazaré ele nem por aqui tudo e aqui
pedir o seu voto a pokémon que tá na
bíblia é nem [ __ ] um capítulo 3
versículo 7 parte berrot em um falar o
que eu volto melhor volta como se fosse
entrar e você pode ter toda uma
segurança do avast toda a segurança do
norte vista ou você pode ter um cavalo
de tróia também pra jesus em mombaça
tinguá timing de jesus a prova você deve
estar pensando agora eu sou contra uma
pessoa religiosa será candidato nada a
ver navios ou quantas pessoas chantagear
e as outras com a palavra de deus para
poder entrar na política plena certeza
que tem muito cristão é muito evangelho
com boa intenção e até na política no
blog que chantageou joão de deus eu
quero que você comente aqui embaixo que
você mais odeia no horário eleitoral eu
também queria pedir que se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo você concordou com o
que eu falei aqui você clica não gostei
e não gostei e me ajuda demais demais
demais assim fazer vídeo você está no
facebook serviço que o facebook dá uma
partida ele marcou um amigo seu e nos
comentários pela subir também viu no
twitter que ele vai rp passar para mais
pessoas
a primeira vez assistir o vídeo no canal
sic que inscreveu toda vez que tiver o
idoso vai saber é night e df